they're so mad at me because so I
tweeted out you know they're like oh but
this woman she tweeted buzzfeed's
shutting down because you know people
just don't want fair and accurate
reporting or whatever that's the reason
yeah and I was yeah right and I'm like
well Tim cast is is certified nearly
perfect certification from News Guard
and we're expanding so I don't know what
your what Your excuses what's buzzfeed's
excuse they got super angry that I that
I'm basically rubbing salt into the
wound yeah but it feels good yeah I mean
I used to come after you
many times yeah that's they started it a
little bit I'm sure some of those places
have run some not so nice articles right
yeah hoping to post actually I don't
know where they're at now but when I
went to Sweden the Ogden post actually
wrote the most accurate depiction of
what happened in Sweden I was actually
surprised oh I used to love them Ariana
Huffington I thought she was great in
2011. you used to read Huffington Post I
would see it because I was working at
mines when we were starting mines so
we'd be sourcing stories from all over
the place and that was one of the places
I'd find relatively good stuff compared
it should be at the beginning of it like
it wasn't open for girls right